Theo The Washington Post, các quan trình nghĩ bài tò lo ngại về việc kêu hàng nhéng trong thế lộ hàng trình trên mò hốc, trong suông đồ người y văn tại Trung đâm,
mua tên trở biết có hơn tắng trên nguyên quả để được sự giộng trong vào một tháng qua khiến lượng dự chữ tại thúc bật giảm xù mất được một tài là đáng bao đều.
Một số quan trí trở rằng nếu không có viện pháp bột xong, họ thế lửa tại Trung đâm có thể sớm cảnh,
một ní phải cần như đường chuyển vố kỹ từ các cuộc đực khác như ảnh đủ dân thải đường dân,
đồng thời các cuộc tháng lận nội bộ cũng tập trông và vào việc tăng tóc sản xuất nhẹn đã bình như cơm xa hàng.
Theo ước tính của các chuyện gia, cầm giấu thế lợi trong mà hốc của Mỹ trước xung đột,
sau động từ khoảng 8 niệng đến 4 niệng năm trong quả, tuy nhiên về sự giộng trong nhiều trí xe cầm đầy,
đã làm giảm đáng tệ của một dự chữ.
Vậy lợi đồng các dễn chưa công bố còn số cuộc thệ, nhưng thần định vẫn đủ nâng lượng đặc ứng tệ yêu cầu tác chiến,
với chuyên gia cầm mà áo với suy giảm khó thế lợi của thế tạo ra phích thức, trong cân đủ chữ lợi của sự thần cầu.